hello I trust adults all the speakers in
the previous lots all made the jokes
about you being here after the party
yesterday right so I will not repeat
them so today I wanted to talk to you
about a subject that is rarely at center
of attention when we talk about web
development we will not talk about data
visualization field as such in general
we will mostly talk about practical
applications in web development so just
to make sense of the room how many of
your front-end web developers how many
of your other developers would touch
front-end once in a while okay that's
that's a good mix and any data
scientists or bi professionals okay and
business people there is no shame I'm a
bit of a business person myself okay no
that's good so that's basically a good
audience for this so data is eating the
world and I don't know if it's an
absolute truth but they say that every
year we generate more data then in the
previous whole history come by every
year we generate more data than the
whole previous history combined so how
do we make sense of all that data so if
your name is neo or you an accountant
then maybe you can look at the raw data
and make sense out of it it's always
amazing to me how accountants tell me
that no give me that thousand by
thousand Excel spreadsheet I don't need
your charts just give me the numbers I
can make sense out of it but for the
rest of us it's probably much easier to
understand the data when we look and
visualized in some form of charts or
graphs so what is data visualization so
I like this definition by Lynda Kirk so
data visualization is the representation
and presentation of data to facilitate
understanding short unclear mm-hmm so a
few of you who know me may be wondering
why I'm talking about this subject
because I'm mostly in the previous years
and mostly the talks and other
activities in the windows development
space and then an app marketing and my
name is ancient space but actually and
actually three years ago here at NDC I
gave a talk on an in-app advertising so
why data visualization
so I've started my Korean and the whole
first part of my career was in web
development and then about 2008 and I
switched to more of a native development
and join my friends at am charts to work
on the.net part of the charting control
so that's where I got interested in data
visualization then I could started a
company called a duplex which does
advertising in Windows apps is probably
some of you know the whole Windows Phone
acro system and and and Windows in
general didn't go as far as we hoped so
the company is doing ok we're doing ok
but the market is sort of stagnant so I
got a little bored and I started helping
my friends the time charts again with
some content and articles about data
visualization I've seen what awesome
things are possible now that were
impossible ten years ago and got
interested in data visualization again
so after this long introduction to
people to a few people who know me it's
probably good to introduce myself to
people who don't so my name is Alan
Moon's Levitch and come from Vilnius
Lithuania
besides being CEO at a duplex and
helping my friend Sam in a time chart
I'm also a Microsoft MVP in Windows
development for at least two more weeks
hopefully they will renew me again but
but there is no guarantee in this face
so we'll see and so in the agenda for
today is pretty straightforward so
basically what we'll cover cover the
past the present and the future of data
visualization and I like to separate
this periods by the role data
visualization played in in the whole web
development space so in the past we just
use charts to illustrate the text of
tables or whatever we had on the page
just as an image illustration now we can
do more things we can interact with
charts we can make some more sense of it
can I believe in the future data
visualization will take a most central
part and be like the main charts and
graphs will be the main part of any web
app so let's go quickly through the past
and let's start with the cheesy quote to
remind you why it's important
so at first we just used a fixed-width
font you know add some access to your
code and voila you have a bar chart
awesome then we realize that we can take
a single single pixel give stretch it to
the dimensions we take and get a pretty
decent looking bar chart anyone does
done this before
Yeah right so and obviously the laziest
way of them all just create your chart
in Excel save it as an image and
including your page awesome your data
visualization drop is done so later on
tools that we can characterize as
server-side generators appear and like
the signature piece of software in the
nineties was a cool tool called
webalizer anyone heard about it used it
right so so basically this this was a
process that ran on your web server and
analyzed your web server logs and every
night it would generate you a
nice-looking report to to see how how
your site does basically the Google
Analytics of the 90s so for those of you
have net who have never seen it I will
show you a quick demo apparently it's
still online it has this beautiful
website I especially like this badge on
it which is probably relevant again with
all the stuff that's going on around
Microsoft's acquisition of github so
maybe we will see more badges like this
in the future and so so the reports look
like this you know doesn't look modern
but you still get the all the charts you
get all the data and pretty much
everything that you get from Google
Analytics except for the you know
privacy violation and stuff like that
yeah so then we started getting like
this charting libraries that we could
use in our back-end code so on the PHP
side we had JP graph on the dotnet side
we had done this charts then Microsoft
added ice p.net chart control to the
whole ice p.net toolkit and the final
product is in this
lineup of server-side tools was Google
charts which now is a pretty modern
client-side charting library but in its
first iteration it was generating images
on the server on the server but was what
was special about it is that it
generated these images based on the data
you you pass to it via the HTTP request
so you basically sent along along h-2b
request to it put it in in the image tag
on your site and in that request in the
query string you passed the data and it
returns an image so what that was pretty
awesome at the time but it still
generated all the images on the server
and besides all of these images being
static non interactive and other things
the main the main drawback of all of
these server-side generating tools was
just that it was in the name that all
the images were generated on the server
and for charts this quite usually means
that it's a computationally intense
process to generate an image for every
visitor to your site so it was a very
very heavy load on the server's back
then so enough about the past let's
let's talk about present so looking at
the slide you may ask Alan is this slide
deck like seven years old or something
flash and present what's up is that
reality is that all the modern
techniques that we use in web data
visualization these days were started in
mid 2000s in flash and basically when
the writing of flash was on the wall
we've actually spent like several years
trying to replicate what we were able to
do in flash in in modern standard web
technologies
so when today we are doing it mostly
with JavaScript and SVG so you can also
do it with canvas and this is mostly
applicable to charge web performance is
the main the main aspect that you care
about but for the most like practical
charge that you use in everyday your
dashboards and stuff like that you would
probably use SVG
so most of you know SVG as vector
graphics format but how many of you know
that it has the full full-featured
document object model that you can
manipulate from JavaScript and do
awesome things with it so let lets let's
see how we do that yeah so here we have
empty basically a HTML page is the phone
big enough so what this generates is
this square this rectangle that is
shaded sky-blue so let's add something
that looks like a simple bar chart to it
so we add a line that will represent our
axis we can show we do like the one end
of it and then we add the other end of
it
and we just make it black and then we
had one bar so the coordinates are
obviously the coordinates go from top to
bottom but we actually want to go our
bar go from what onto top so even here
we would have to do some calculations if
we want to draw some real data here
so what what we have now is this like
one bar on an axis so I trust that you
don't want to watch me type all the time
so let's add more bars like this and now
we have something that that looks like
some basic bar shirt so another awesome
things about nice thing about SVG that
you can actually do animations
declaratively right in the SVG so we
have here one bar that we put an idea of
demo bar on it and then we can animate
it but we will change the value of it
but since as I mentioned the coordinates
go from top to bottom and our bar goes
from bottom to top we actually need to
change its height and also move the top
left corner up at the same time so if we
add this maybe get this basic animation
so cool stuff right right in the
declaratively but the problem is this is
this that I switch animations are not
supported in IE and edge and will
probably not be supported in the near
future luckily we have many other ways
you can do any animations with SVG but
first let's let's add as I mentioned
before that we can add objects to it for
JavaScript so let's just add some basic
circle to it
so we basically grab the SVG on our page
create a circle in the SVG namespace and
then send set a bunch of attributes on
it using the setattribute method which
we have to do unfortunately if you want
to do SVG with vanilla yes and then we
insert it in our SVG so unlike HTML and
there is no concept of explicit that
index in SVG so you basically have to
put everything into the Dom in the order
you want it to be rendered on on on an
image so if I want that circle to be
behind bars then we have to insert it
behind bars so we have this now so let's
try to animate
again and we can do it with CSS
animations like you would do with HTML
so again just use the IDE and do a basic
animation let's move it off the screen a
bit so it looks better so it doesn't
start in the middle of the screen and
you have your circle moving across SVG
and finally let's instead of animating
it with SVG let's animate it with
JavaScript
yes so what we're doing here we are
calling a move circle method every 10
milliseconds and that method yet an
x-coordinate from the circle object and
then adds one to it and then moves it
back to the start and sets the attribute
back so pretty much the same just
without the nice easing that we had with
CSS animation so that's a basic demo of
accessing a switch if I switch you from
JavaScript and doing a declaratively in
HTML so as you seen there is a lot of
writing involved and a lot of magic
strings if you want to do it just the
vanilla JavaScript way you have to call
the set attribute all the time and you
have to pass that attribute as a string
so libraries to the rescue
there are several libraries that help
you work with SVG's from javascript one
is called SVG dodge is the other is snap
SVG and what it would look like in in
those libraries so this is a basic code
that you would have to do to create an
SVG and place rectangle in it with
vanilla genius and with the su gjs is
basically two lines of code so we could
have done that much much with much less
code if we use some library but if we
are doing charts it's probably a good
idea just to do some charting library
luckily there are hundreds and thousands
of them and I know if thousands but
hundreds definitely that can help you
with this ranging from simple open
source to complex and commercial so I
will show you just one demo with an open
source library called Chartist so all
you have to do is include the library in
your code this is data so you can
discount it it's just data and then you
just call one line pass that data so you
pass the where to put the
art and you get this chart that looks
like this you get like axis labels for
free you get the grid for free and most
importantly you get responsiveness for
free so much easier to do like this then
then try to reinvent the wheel and do it
yourself
so I've shown you the basic demo but if
you want to see what awesome things can
be done with JavaScript and SVG look up
the stock by Saturday as nur s which you
can do that and you will see a lot of
awesome things I will show you just one
so this was done with just SVG in
JavaScript so basically if you look at
the code you have an SVG with a lot of
passes in it that that was created
probably in Illustrator or something
like this and then you have the
JavaScript code that animates it and
that's it so what defines a modern
JavaScript modern data visualization
library for the web so most the modern
charts are interactive so users can poke
around them explore the data and do
other things
they are also usually animated so you as
a developer or someone who made the
charts can draw users attention to
what's important in the chart and most
importantly they are all client-side now
so we're leaving the servers across the
world from the heavy task of generating
those them images so we use them in
dashboards and reports like Google
Analytics we use them in infographics so
previously if you wanted to do we wanted
to create a nice infographic you had to
hire some agency or have some department
or only the company can do it could do
that
but nowadays we stools like info Graham
and others you can just go to a website
and create an infographic right there
right in your browser and all of this
done with modern JavaScript charging
technologies so here are just a few
examples of infographics that could be
done that way
if you're really interested even
remotely interested in data
visualization I highly recommend you
watch this talk by David McCandles
who does a lot of like infographics
based on data big data sets and he
distills them into basically one page
one page infographics that you can
analyze and enjoy and have fun and learn
something in the process so let me show
you just one this is the map of of the
world with each country labeled as what
it's best at anyone seen dies before so
if we zoom into our region for some
reason it says that Norway is best at
eating pizza does this make sense to you
I do like who likes pizza ok so the
previous version of this infographic so
this was updated in 2006 I've seen like
I had a book and I've seen the earlier
one in that book Norway was best at
drinking coffee so that I can believe
at least judging by the low-low
selection of tea you have here so
probably like coffee and my country
Lithuania in the latest version is best
of fastest Wi-Fi which is much much much
much better than what we had in the
previous version anyone wants to guess
so we in the what now it will be much
better than what we had so in the
previous version we were best at
suicides so I will take fastest Wi-Fi
over suicides any day so if you if you
like beautiful stuff just buy one of the
books from David my candles or both of
the books you can have them as your
coffee table book basically there are no
words in it except for the labels in the
infographic you have on every page you
have an awesome infographic that you can
put you know on your table and when you
have a minute that you're bored you just
take the book and analyze one
infographic learn something in and see
something beautiful or you can you know
get sucked in and spend countless hours
analyzing the book
and looking for awesome stuff in there
and it's great so we also use
visualization in more pragmatic things
like our BI tools like power bi and
tableau you can use it right in the
service or you can in case of power bi
you can embed into your app and use it
that way and obviously there is a whole
profession a whole like movement of
people who are actually data
visualization professionals who have
data visualization in there in the job
title so these people do exist they have
conferences they have podcasts and they
can talk about it way in a way where
more detail than I can and for most of
the of them on the web the library of
choice is d3 yes so this is an awesome
library that can do a lot of things but
it's it it mainly targeted at those
people who can who want to do things
that are not standard who will never be
satisfied with standard things so if you
want to do a simple thing it's much more
difficult to do with d3 than with many
other charting libraries that are aimed
at pH at normal web developers who just
want to do great data visualization and
their admin dashboard or something like
this so let me show you a few of the
three demos so this is quite a simple
ones basically a bar chart that flips
from stack to grouped a little bit more
elaborate so this is a polar chart that
was made to be a clock so it shows
current time and date as a chart so you
can do like chart but not really chart
or you can do totally random things with
d3 which just demonstrate what library
can do so I think d3 will continue to to
lead on the bleeding edge of data
visualization and professionals will
continue to use it but I think the
market will demand a lot of from like
regular web developers when when you're
like business person sees an awesome
chart that your competitor made they
would want you to make something
although and and if you are not a data
visualization professional you will
probably look at some other libraries
that democratize this that make it
easier for a normal developer to achieve
awesome things and to think in the
future we will use the visualizations
for more things than just illustrating
our data we can tell awesome stories
with data visualization and this helps
us deliver the message in more engaging
way and also it helps us transcend the
language barrier so if you can show a
story with data visualization you don't
need to translate it into 50 languages
or something - if you want to get
inspired about storytelling with data
visualization I suggest you'd watch this
chat by Hans Rosling so this talk is
like more than 10 years old I think it's
like yeah it's from 2006 and back then
and they had to create their custom
software to to do all this storytelling
with data visualization luckily it's
quite within reach for normal web
developers these days so this is a
modern version of their extreme poverty
visualization so what it shows is that
in like in 1800 most of the population
on the earth lived in extreme poverty
and then we starting started living a
bit better and the chart was moving to
the right it moves in moves you can you
can filter stuff here by region by
country will be probably better if it
included some some like major events
like Wars and stuff like that and you
can see that by now we are doing
relatively okay so 12% is still a big
number but definitely better than 85 so
it you can tell a story this way another
interesting data visualization that
tells the story is this chart made by
ant sleeping and from
Finnish meteorological Institute so he
made a visualization of temperature
changing on earth over the last hundred
years so you can see here that you know
the temperature is growing and you've
probably seen hundreds or maybe
thousands of of articles about climate
change and global warming and if you see
another headline like this again you
just skip it because you've seen it many
times before but this is a visualization
he was able to get more than ten
thousand three tweets and it was last
year when everyone was already slightly
bored of all all these headlines about
global warming so and to do that he had
to he did that with a custom Python
script that rendered the visualization
as a video but there is no reason we
cannot do this with with more than web
technologies these days so basically we
can do it with JavaScript and SVG like
this it would be interactive you could
select things in it and it doesn't have
to be a video in this day and age yet so
another story anyone knows where this is
so this is a why and how many of you
have heard about this fake missile alert
that happened like a few months ago okay
how many many of you know this website
no hands one hand two hands
okay so does anyone know what these two
have in common
let me show you oh this
okay we'll skip this for now so
this is a chart from pornhub about their
traffic from Hawaii on the day that
missile alert went out so as you can see
here you know the traffic fluctuates
around average so it goes a little
higher guy goes a little lower and that
continues throughout day then Koreans
apparently launch a rocket and it flys
flys flys and someone pushes the button
and alert goes out and the traffic to
pornhub planets and and then the alert
is canceled and everything is back to
more normal everyone is happy the live
continuous so as you can see we can tell
this story with state of visualization
and make it engaging then actually
foreign hubs themselves they posted this
as an image and they had to accommodate
it with a lengthy article about it which
is also which is also was also
fascinating but I can see I can imagine
that looking at it interactively is way
more engaging okay so when you see
infographics you often see different
types of chart mixed into one graphic
but when you look at your like average
dashboard charts or like any practical
charts you almost never see this so why
is that so one thing is obviously that
not every type of data is well-suited to
be expressed that way and obviously just
because you can do it you shouldn't do
it but you never see it because it's
until now it was quite difficult to do
with standardized data visualization
libraries and almost impossible to do
but there is no reason why we can do it
in 2008 so if if that makes sense to you
if that makes your UI more engaging and
for the user why not do it we can also
use data visualization elements is just
a UI so on the left side here you see
google analytics were you basically
where everything is done basically the
old-school way you have your chart with
visualizing data then you have controls
to you know to filter that data or you
click on some link to drill down into
that data and stuff like that on the
right side you see power bi where
basically everything is data
visualization and you can click on that
data visualization you can select
something in that data visualization and
filter all the other charts on the page
based on that so you can use that to
create your drill downs you can filter
data based on it or you can just link
out with that straight from
visualization so let's look at some more
demos so this is this looks basically
like a normal map it's interactive you
can work around it see something but
when you click on a country the country
transforms to two to a pie chart that
show you some stats about that country
and click on the other country if she
starts about that other country and so
on and you don't never leave the
visualization and previously would
probably do even if you made the map you
would click on the map and go to some
other page and if you want to see the
other country you would go down and go
back click on another country or you
will create some combo box that that
filters country so checkboxes why not
just do it in in the chart itself so the
one we have seen before so over here and
like in video you can you know drill
down and see only American country so
you can go back and only see Europe or
you can select just a few countries and
do it all in the chart without any other
controls so this is three map of car
sales in the US in 2017 you can see that
for this number one and you can drill
down and see what Ford models most
popular and when the last time I've
shown this visualization to a bunch of
gigs they the first question was where's
Tesla so Tesla is still in other you can
go here in five
Tesla NC sales by model this is power bi
so this is a report of of traffic to an
app so the the black bars are returning
users the green bars and new users and
this is Mountain so you can click on one
of the bars and then all the other
charts on the page are filtered by
returning users and that month and you
click back and you click on the new
users and all the other charts are
filtered by that another like more
conceptual example so you have like two
pie charts here and you can drag slices
from one pie chart to another practical
application still remains to be seen but
but you can do this and you can I don't
know maybe sort items into buckets in
some awesome way ok so now we have a lot
of IOT sensors we have light bulbs we
have whatever sensors we have across our
homes and in the world at large so a lot
of data comes from these services and
you need to handle it and this is one of
the if you want to visualize the data
this is one of the places where canvas
based charts are probably more suitable
than SVG based charts because you know
in canvas you just draw a pixel and
forget about it
and if you want to do this with SVG you
get a lot of objects and at some point
your browser explodes but another way to
handle this is to aggregate historic
data in and show it as an aggregate and
you can do that as well the same applies
to machine learning in the eye and the
additional aspect here is quite often
when you apply some logic that you as a
person don't understand what's going on
so you may get a result that is of a
shape that you don't know how to display
up front
so you can either either try to guess or
you can give your viewers an option to
change the chart type do other things
with with how the data is visualized to
make it more useable to them so this is
like a fake real time chart this gets a
data item once a second so you can do
all all the nice things we can do with
SVG charts here you know it's beautiful
it moves through scales etc and imagine
if we got like thousands of data items
every second it would probably die
pretty quickly so here we have like a
chart with data that comes in every
minute so it looks okay if we look at it
as one hour then when we get to two
hours it gets Messier and then we move
out and it get even Messier so why not
just at some point we just flip and show
it in ten minutes intervals and if we
have more data we can then go to an hour
to a week to a month and so on as I
mentioned we don't always know what
would be the best shape to represent the
charge of it so we may some users may
want to look at it as a radial chart
someone to look at it as a normal bar
chart we can give them that option as
well and this is a quick insights
feature of power bi which basically
looks at your data and tries to guess
what's interesting in it like 95% of its
total nonsense because it correlates
whatever is whatever but sometimes you
get some interesting insights here but
as you can see that you're quite every
one of them is special and I think
they'd probably do a good job of finding
the right chart to visualize the data
but if you don't have the time to
or the skills to to find the best chart
for every generated output from your
machine learning or AI stuff you can
just give that option to your user to
switch the chart type another like
canonical example of bad charting
situations is is when you have outliers
so like 300 ours looks like this so you
can see that you know the first bar is
much bigger than the others but if then
if you want to compare the smaller bars
they have very all very similar in in
this at this scale so in print and in
static images many designers to this but
then data visualization professionals
say no no no you cannot do this because
you skew the whole the whole picture if
if normal person looks at the in this
picture they think that us is less than
two times bigger in whatever this is in
China but in reality it's like 10 times
bigger or more than 10 times bigger so
but with interactive charts there is no
reason why we cannot accommodate for
both we can give the real picture and we
can give the picture that lets us look
at all the other bars in this chart in a
interesting fashion that lets us analyze
what's going on in the whole rest of the
chart obviously the whole world moved
mobile when it comes to like
professional or intense data
visualization you many people still
probably do it on their desktops or
laptops but still a lot of people do it
on mobile and your charts should be
touch friendly at the minimum then they
may support multi-touch and stuff like
that and obviously they should be
responsive and I've shown you the
responsive example with Chartist which
is the base which is the minimum that
they should do but there are there is
more so let's look at few more demos so
this is a simple bar chart but it
supports multi-touch you can again
practical application and I know maybe
you can build a equalizer with it
something like this you can do multiple
at a time or or the the one that I've
shown you was dragging the slices I
actually did it on on the touchscreen
and it definitely should be supported in
2018 another thing is responsiveness so
you can just so normally when you show a
pie chart or a doughnut chart like in
this case you would place labels around
the chart this this helps people
understand what's going on here better
but if you go down at some point it gets
messy all the labels taking all the
space and the chart itself is too small
so at this point it's probably better to
switch to a legend and show show file
I'll show the chart separately
accessibility is the big topic recently
and this is where essage using SVG
shines because it's a markup language
where you can use all the tools you can
use with HTML you can use all the Aria
label Aria attributes etc same things
that you use with HTML you can also help
users by allowing them to change the
color scheme of your chart as someone
some of the speakers joke that you know
a colorblind person couldn't vote here
because you know they have green green
papers and the red papers and if you're
a green red colorblind how can you vote
so when you do data visualizations think
about that as well
you can do a high contrast theme so you
can just replace colors with patterns
that helps people who are colorblind and
many of you have probably dealt with
gdpr or still deal with gdpr and related
stuff and that made a lot of people
rethink what we can do with our data how
easily can we ship it to a third-party
service like power bi like in the past
you just you need to visualize something
you
upload that data to power bi BAM you
have awesome awesome stuff and then
could could we do this where we are
allowed to ship that data to a data
center in u.s.
I don't know so so now many people are
concerned with this and many move layer
like data back data visualization things
back and this will increase demand for
data visualization skills among their
in-house web developers and obviously
finally we cannot escape talking about
VRA RMR XR whatever you want to call it
so but the question is is there anything
special about charting and VR and Ammar
so power bi have released their app for
mixed reality for hololens and stuff
like that not too long ago and there is
basically nothing special in it when it
concerns data visualization the charts
are just displayed on a plane like light
before and this is probably a good thing
you you know a knee-jerk reaction maybe
to think about something like this when
you have the charts flipping over in you
know 3d but the reality is that even in
this demo they had to make make the bars
very different so you can see what's
going on here
in reality this all all of these 3d
charts are really hard to understand for
people and read so if you are making not
a gimmick but a practical chart you
probably still want to make it to the
chart and there is nothing really
special about doing it in VR or EMR so
that's about it I highly recommend you
look at all of these awesome resources
about data visualization stuff like that
and the next time you are doing a
project that involves some charting and
stuff try to not forget but not think
about how you would do it ten years ago
and just replicate it with new
technologists try to think about what
new technologies enable you to do and
how they enable you to get ahead of your
competition and help your users and take
a look at what my friends them charge do
I also have some of these stickers here
if you want them and I've also this is
totally off topic I've also written a
book called conferences for introverts
that is you as an industry attendee you
can download it for free from that URL
and I have three physical copies here on
the first-come first-served basis if
anyone wants them so thank you very much
and enjoy the rest of indicee
[Applause]